Well,
science is a very,
it's actually very difficult field
because you need probably above
everything else extraordinary patients.
Okay.
And what keeps you going is discovery.
And sometimes,
uh,
in a lifetime you may have one
outstanding discovery.
Um,
Einstein used to say that,
that he was unusual in that he had had
too,
but any one would have been enough to
have kept him going.
Um,
most scientists are not in that league,
but we all have at some scale,
uh,
things that were know,
really very proud of.
If we do,
if we discover them,
um,
often we are looking for them.
Okay.
Uh,
the idea that a lot of discovery is
serendipitous and accidental is
tremendously,
tremendously overplayed.
Uh,
I think it's much more likely that once
see something almost in everyday life
that puzzles you and you carry it around
with you for some period of time and
then you see some way of connecting to
it.
Okay.
Uh,
you could say our discoveries and autism
is an example of that.
At a very early age.
I was impressed by this child and later
saw an opportunity and I struck when the
opportunity was there to satisfy my
curiosity.
So most discoveries of that tough.
Sometimes you see things that you can't
explain and action say sometimes a lot
of time you see things that you can't
explain.
Um,
and sometimes you come up with
explanations that are really exciting
and 99% of the time those are wrong.
And it's really some trivial explanation
to the thing that's gotten you excited.
Early in my career I used to hate those
things and I used to say,
you know,
only a manic depressive would love
living like this.
You know,
you have,
you see something,
it's weird.
You have,
you come up with some great encompassing
idea that'll explain it.
It's going to change how people think
and then the next day you realize that
you were really a dumb ass.
Nowadays when those things happen,
I actually really enjoy them because
there are so few,
you know,
real Eureka moments in one's life that
you have to almost enjoy the fake ones.
I mean,
after all,
it's it.
The feeling is just as good.
Yeah.
So I've actually gotten to enjoy those,
those weird results that we can't
explain.
Um,
come up with fanciful ideas and then try
to batter them,
and then you get a double satisfaction
because you end up destroying the idea.
And it's satisfying I
to destroy the idea almost as much fun
to destroy an idea's too as to create
one.